i do wonder if it's possible to at scale
encourage each other to approach like
social media and communication with
fellow humans in that way
i don't know how do you think that would
be done i guess like to improve the
improve the quality of discourse maybe
like even like you said the empathy or
the the decency of discourse
i think people should be you know uh
incentivized encouraged to do that i
think
most of what's we see happening on
twitter and facebook and so on
has to do with very small but very
powerful
implementation details it goes down to
like what is the source of the dopamine
rush
the like button uh the sharing
mechanisms
just even small tweaks and those can fix
a lot really
i i believe so so like a lot a lot of
the stuff we see now
is the result of just initial
implementations of these systems
that we didn't anticipate so the
monetization
comes from engagement and the
the tools we have is clicking like and
sharing it was not always obvious it was
not obvious from the beginning it wasn't
obvious while the twitter and facebook
grew that there's a big dopamine rush
from getting more followers and likes
and
shares so we've gotten addicted to this
feeling like how many people are
commenting how many people are saying
like a clicking like and so on so that's
that dopamine rise so we want to say the
thing they'll get the most likes
on and like unmask in society
and then the other thing that was
expected is the controversial the
divisive
will get the most likes so we it had to
do with the initial mechanisms of likes
and shares
resulting in an outcome that was
unpredicted which is
huge amounts of division irrespective of
like
any of the basics of human connection
that we've actually all come
to understand society is valuable at the
individual level
like we're saying but on mass what
results is like you throw all that out
and it's all just divisive
at scale uh
discourse uh i think it could be fixed
by
incentivizing personal growth like
incentivizing you to challenge yourself
to grow as individual and most
importantly to
be happy at the end of the day so
uh feed like incentivize
you feeling good as in
in a way that's long-lasting long-term i
think what makes people actually feel
good
is being kind to others long term
in the short term what feels good is
getting a lot of likes
and i think those are just different
incentives
that if implemented correctly you could
just build social networks that would do
much better
so do you think it comes from a
structural perspective i guess at what
point does you mention like
you mentioned free will and also you
mentioned uh you know feeling good like
and again working hard you know do you
i know that you have the uh i guess the
i was it a race or um
no it's oh the the the goggins thing
yeah uh it's four by forty
four by four by 48 challenge where you
run four miles every four hours for
two days that's awesome yeah it's it's a
bunch of it's it's uh
the the the challenge of it isn't just
the running the running is very tough
but
it's mostly the sleep deprivation rises
you're just training every four hours
but it's a struggle right
and that's wrong but the struggle gives
meaning and ultimately i guess so how
can we
because you mentioned like you said
adjusting things on like a uh
i guess like a programming level almost
uh based programming levels so that the
interface is different for the user
but at what point does the user have a
responsibility to
you know as a as a man or a woman or a
person to just
behave more decently how can we i guess
utilize
what can we do it seems like you know
we're like our society is so grossly
missing like a martin luther king right
now like the great inspiring characters
throughout american history throughout
world history where are the great
leaders
so leadership is part of it but i you
know that's definitely word the great
leader is a very good question that's
that's more of a question of
our political systems why they're not
pushing forward the great leaders but
there's also just uh okay
there's uh some just basic engineering
[ __ ] which is
when you and i when you ryan and i are
in a room alone
and we're talking even if we're
strangers the incentives
are for us to get along like just when
we're
together in person that's what i'm
saying i'm not even saying some kind of
but
when you remove that when we remove that
the the the
implementation of of the of social
networks as they stand
right now in the digital space have very
different set of incentives
it's more fun to destroy others to be
shitty to others
and that and it becomes this little
endless loop
like you were saying that's ultimately
destructive and not productive and i
think
it has to do with just the interfaces of
making it feel good to be nice to others
because currently it doesn't feel nearly
as good
to be nice to others on the internet and
it it doesn't feel nearly as bad
as it does in real life to be shitty to
others on the internet so the incentives
are just wrong
i i think there is a technology solution
to this
or at least the solution to improve this
uh this communication mechanism
you